what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so normally we would have done
Batman the white knight on Wednesday but
we covered Dark Knight's medal and so
we're covering this today but this will
come back like next week we'll cover on
Wednesday like I prefer to keep this
every week on a Wednesday that way you
guys can expect to you know see the
videos come out but this is continuing
to be just such an amazing story and
it's such a cool story because the Joker
is so smart like I love the way this is
done by Shawn Murphy the whole story so
far is that Jack Napier is basically
gone saying that Joker's turn into a
sane human being and has decided that
it's basically his responsibility to
conquer the city of Gotham to basically
take it over using the will of the
people and that he's essentially
ensnared the various villains you know
poison ivy and Bane and two-face and all
these different people using the power
of the Mad Hatter basically slipping all
these people mind-control nanomachines
odd the Mad Hatter uses and in turn
doing it through two-face feeding them
drinks and then controlling their minds
using the actual headband of two-face
but it's cool because what this does is
this opens up basically with like all
the villains of Gotham just launching an
attack on the city of Gotham itself and
of course it requires the entire bat
family to respond and at this point it
really only consists of like Batman
Batgirl and Nightwing Dick Grayson and
that's really about it so it's pretty
short as it is now they also have the
police who were fighting on their side
but what is up happening here is you
have all these different villains who
are basically rampaging across the
larger city of Gotham with Batman
heading to back port which is where you
know a handful of them are somewhat at
and where initially Commissioner
Gordon's idea is we all have to head to
back port we all have to help out Batman
at the end of the day Bullock and and
even other people like Renee Montoya are
just kind of like no no no no Batman can
handle himself we need to focus on the
larger problem in in the main Gotham
City itself now of course what this does
is it kind of puts in a strop relief the
idea that Batman's willing to go to any
lengths to take down the Joker and it
almost makes Batman look like he's not
looking at the big picture because what
isn't happening is he basically says
like the Joker's behind this we have to
find the Joker you know we can go to
back court we can take these guys out
they're not going to destroy the library
the Joker just built there's no way
that's gonna happen but it does and
again it's brilliant here because the
Joker when he went saying he basically
made the case that Batman does
everything he can to take down villains
with no real thought to the collateral
damage Batman doesn't care about who
gets displaced from their homes when
buildings are destroyed family doesn't
really care about how much it cost to
rebuild things when he
stuff all he cares about is getting the
bad guy and this fits directly into that
notion because bein in Killer Croc start
tearing down the library but to
everybody who's watching all this unfold
Batman chased down a couple of villains
quartered them and they freaked out and
destroyed a building it's Batman's fault
that's how people will see it that's how
they will perceive it now Batman runs in
there and basically tries to subdue
these guys but gets caught in you know
all the destruction and everything only
for like to face and Killer Croc to
basically have gotten away so Batman is
perceived as being single-handedly
responsible for the destruction of all
these different things now at this point
we switch over to Joker himself to Jack
Napier and we end up finding out this
was exactly what we thought it was it
was just a distraction his idea was to
basically wait until the smoke cleared
and then go to the Law Offices of Hill
and Hill the former Law Offices of the
current mayor Hill in Gotham City and
what he does is start sifting through
all these old files
he starts sifting through all this old
information all these little secrets and
things like that that are not supposed
to be readily known now what we end up
finding out is a reason for this is
because he basically goes in front of
national television and he says what you
guys don't know is that like people are
profiteering off of you every single
time Batman ghostified a villain money
has to be spent in order to fix the
buildings that he's destroyed in order
to repair the roads that are damaged or
whatever the case may be and the
question that that that Jack Napier
presents here the Joker presents here is
where does this money come from who's
spending the money to do this and this
is what he basically makes the
announcement of what's called the Batman
devastation fund that unbeknownst to all
the people in Gotham that what's been
happening is exactly what we discovered
in the last video that you have this
kind of tax payer relief fund more or
less that taxes have been increased or
whatever the case may be
there's kind of a disaster relief fund
that exists out there but because
there's no real natural disasters in
Gotham this is a ruse it's a way for the
wealthy to essentially funnel taxpayer
money into the Batman devastation fund
and then as we discovered in the last
video what they do is they basically
repair these buildings and then that
drop that you'll when when that man
destroys an area it drives down the cost
of everything so the wealthy can
basically repair these buildings improve
on them dirt cheap and then sell them at
top dollar they're using taxpayer money
to basically charge taxpayers more money
for the houses they have to buy or buy
back in order to return to where it was
that they work when Batman destroyed
so again it's pretty heinous what Jack
Napier is doing is he's sitting down and
he's revealing kind of the truth he's
basically showing the man behind the
curtain in the city of Gotham and saying
your city is rampant with corruption
like you wouldn't believe
now this is big because let's say for
example that like this sparked a
revolution in the city of Gotham and
let's say that like the government and
the wealthy they basically like bring in
the National Guard well the National
Guard has brothers and sisters and
mothers and fathers and sons and
daughters who are just the people of
Gotham and I would bet all the money in
my pockets - all the money in your
pockets that if it came down to those
police officers and those National
Guardsmen and National Guard's women who
have been set on the path of trying to
quell this revolution but if they have
to make the choice between pointing a
gun on the wealthy and the powerful who
caused all this or pointing a gun on
their own friends and family they'll
point a gun on the wealthy and powerful
and in that moment it would come into
sharp relief the idea that the wealthy
and the government have no power and
that's the cool thing because once that
goes away once that that line of defense
vanishes then suddenly it's open season
it's really really interesting it's a
way for Jack Napier to win the people
because that's all you ever really need
now at this point we pick up with Bruce
Wayne of course returning back to the
Batcave kind of fixing himself up and so
on and so forth but then Alfred wakes up
when Batman basically collapses and
because of this what is up happening is
Alfred actually removes himself from
wherever it is he's been healing from
and puts Batman in its place this is
cool because what this does is it
actually kills Alfred Alfred basically
sacrifices his life in order to heal
Batman now in truth Shaun Murphy doesn't
make this in like a great big huge like
one-shot right it's not like a brunt of
the story because it doesn't need to be
a great big huge thing because we know
it's a huge thing Alfred dying for the
sake of straight of saving Bruce Wayne
is insane and is huge
Alfred is the moral compass of Bruce
Wayne if Alfred's not there
Batman will just run a ride there'll be
no one to reel him in when he starts to
cross over that line that he's always
tried to keep from crossing over and so
what happens is you have Dick Grayson
you have Barbara Gordon you sit down and
say it's up to us we're the ones that
basically have to hold Batman back and
keep him from crossing over and losing
his mind in its entirety something else
what I want you guys to notice too and
this is this is a pretty cool moment
it's actually one of my favorite moments
in the story the Shawn Murphy shifted
things up in a pretty in a pretty
using an interesting way here while
Barbara Gordon and Dick Grayson are at
the cemetery basically you know paying
paying their respects to Alfred there's
a tombstone there for adjacent Todd now
our initial response would be Jason Todd
was killed by the Joker you know you was
basically beat up with a crowbar and
then blown to pieces and Batman didn't
get there in time and so on and so forth
no no that's not what happens what Shaun
Murphy actually tells us is that Jason
Todd was Robin before Dick Grayson and
that's huge
it's cool like it's really really cool
to me that's why I like these stories
that are kind of out there is because to
me telling the same chronology all the
time gets really really boring and
really mundane
and shifting things up just enough to
make them different is actually really
really interesting to me because Dick
Grayson doesn't really know anything
about Jason Todd all they know is that
Jason Todd's death kind of set in motion
the reality of the fact that you can't
save everybody
the Batman couldn't save every single
person that mattered but from here what
we also do is pick up with another
little bit of a change and we basically
have the Joker who shows up in backport
and actually meets with Duke Thomas now
Duke Thomas is grown he's a grown man in
this instance and again this is really
fascinating to me because Duke Thomas in
the main DC line of comics is young I
mean he's basically the signal I mean
it's Batman in the signal we don't
really know exactly what he's gonna be
but we know he's not going to be a Robin
we're just kind of waiting for his
character to be fleshed out but in this
story he's grown he's fought in the
military you know he's basically like
Special Forces for a while he's kind of
like the guy who doesn't really trust
Jack Napier but he's somewhat of the
tour guide here because what Duke says
is that I don't necessarily trust you
but backport loves you because back port
views Jack Napier as the only guy who's
on their side they view him as the only
guy who's willing to help them out and
again this sets in stone the idea that
the Joker's hitting all the right marks
that he's getting all the right support
from all the right people
now what this also does is this hits of
the idea that Jack Napier could make a
run for like mayor and basically become
the mayor of Gotham and he would have
the vote support in order to pull it off
and that's again where you start to back
people into a corner and so what we end
up doing here is we actually pick up
with a woman who basically breaks into
the facility of the Joker sort of but
not really but she basically comes
across the Mad Hatter and of course you
know the Mad Hatter is spouting you know
styling different things like you know
Alison Wonderland quotes and so on and
so forth which is what he does but this
woman who's actually not the Joker's
daughter thank God as soon as I saw this
I thought it was like to return
Joker's daughter from like the new 52
you and I was like man I really hope not
them
there were a lot of people who hated the
idea of Joker's daughter The Joker's
daughter was designed to be kind of a
stand-in for like Harley Quinn in the
new 52
he was an attempt to basically replace
her and even kind of replace the Joker
to a degree they give us like a new
version of the Joker or something along
those lines
I have no real idea what the purpose was
and that was evidenced in the fact that
she just kind of floated around and
there was no real story to be told about
her she was kind of interesting in the
beginning but then after that you know
people were just kind of like no give us
the old Joker which I'm glad we did
because we got Scott Snyder's Joker who
was insane but this girl breaks into the
facility only to find out that basically
like Clayface is being controlled with a
car to the Mad Hatter that's been
slipped inside his brain which it's kind
of cool to see the interior of Clayface
once he like turns to dust and fades
away and it's just a brain with eyes
attached to it which I guess still works
at me I don't know how it's getting
oxygen no clue anyway so this chick is
it's cool because she basically like
like the Mad Hatter spills the beans and
says everything that's going on here is
being done by Jack Napier Jack Napier
runs everything no idea what it is of
what do what he's gonna do with it but
Jack Napier is basically running the
entirety of the criminal empire but this
is huge because what this means is that
Jack Napier Secret is no longer a secret
if the word is out now that Jack Napier
is actually the one behind the scenes
pulling the strings when it comes to all
the different villains in Gotham City
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]